Herr Trittin erobern die Russen bachmut
hätten sie freie Bahn sagt woodomir
seelensky kommen die Panzer aus dem
Westen zu spät das wissen wir nicht wir
wissen weder ob diese dieser Fortschritt
so ist wie er ist was richtig ist ist
das natürlich die Waffenlieferung die
wir haben wahrscheinlich
insbesondere was die Nachschub von
Munition angeht nicht das Ausmaß haben
wie es die Ukraine langsam braucht das
ist ja einer der Gründe warum der
Europäische Union jetzt entschieden hat
sowas europäisch zu bestellen um
europäische Größe Stückzahlen zu
erreichen wir werden mindestens in dem
doppelten Umfang der letzten Zusagen der
Amerikaner liefern möglicherweise in der
vierfachen Menge aber das muss jetzt
schnell gehen wie viel Schuld trägt
Deutschland daran darüber werden wir
auch noch diskutieren Norbert Röttgen
ist bei uns ebenfalls außen politische
Außenpolitiker Mitglied im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss die Lage an der Front sei
schwierig sagt sie lensky gleichzeitig
kündigt einer seiner Geheimdienstchefs
eine große ukrainische Offensive an was
ist davon zu halten ist die Lage nun um
bachmut dramatisch oder wird es möglich
sein diese Stadt zu halten
also sowohl als auch wie man hört was
muss man ja immer mit Vorbehalt alles
sagen ich glaube einerseits zeigt im
bachmut wird er seit neun Monaten
gekämpft das heißt also auch russland
versucht eine Kleinstadt ohne
strategische Bedeutung seit neun Monaten
zu erobern und es gelingt nicht das sagt
etwas aus sie verlieren dabei jeden Tag
hunderte von Soldaten
weil sie brauchen also einen
symbolischen Erfolg die Ukraine hat sich
entschieden so wird es jedenfalls
interpretiert auch mit einem hohen
blutzahlen der aber ein Bruchteil des
russischen ist also man sagt so eins zu
vier eins zu fünf im Verhältnis das
heißt aber auch schon viel jeden Tag
jeden Tag sagen durch den Widerstand
eine eine enorm hohe verlustzahl an
Menschen leben und Verwundeten auf
russischer Seite zu erreichen und
gleichzeitig zu versuchen vorzubereiten
für das Frühjahr eine Offensive im Süden
ähm das wird so gesagt mit weiteren
strategischen Überlegungen was den Süden
anbelangt also sozusagen ein eine ein
doppelansatz in bachmut Russland
aufzuhalten und erheblichste wenn
tausende russische Soldaten die die
Armee zu schwächen um dann auch ähm aber
gleichzeitig Kräfte zusammen
um im Süden eine eigene Offensive zu
machen so wird die Planung beschrieben
und so bekommen es auch die Abgeordneten
des Deutschen Bundestages dargestellt
weil auf dieser Basis müssen Sie hier
entscheiden und auch
überwaffenlieferungen entscheiden peter
Neumann ist bei uns Sicherheitsexperte
Spezialist für Sicherheitsfragen und
besonders für terrorfragen aber auch auf
diesem Feld sind sie zu Hause
erneuermann warum eine Stadt von der
viele sagen sie sei nur ein Symbol warum
dann doch von beiden Seiten ein so
brachialer Kampf darum
also ich glaube bachmut ist von beiden
Seiten ein Symbol geworden wie Herr
Röttgen gesagt hat da wird seit neun
Monaten gekämpft das hat erhebliche
symbolische Bedeutung und wir wissen ja
auch aus diesem Krieg dass die Moral
eine genauso große Rolle spielt wie die
Kampfkraft das ist der erste Punkt der
zweite Punkt ist wie auch wie Herr
Röttgen gesagt hat es geht darum die
jeweils andere Seite zu schwächen für
die bevorstehenden offensiven im
Frühling das ist auch ein wichtiger
Punkt ich glaube der dritte Punkt ist
dass wir auf einen
abnutzungskrieg hinauslaufen wo es
jeweils kleine Gelände Gewinne auf der
jeweils anderen Seite gibt aber sich die
die frontverläufe nicht groß verschieben
und das ist glaube ich vielleicht die
pessimistische oder die negative
Nachricht das möglicherweise der
Frontverlauf im Großen und Ganzen
bleibt so bleiben wird
auch darüber werden wir reden nicht ohne
Sabine Adler vorzustellen in der Runde
für den deutschlandfunklange tätig
besonders aus Osteuropa und Moskau
berichtet es gibt Sabine adlerstreit in
der Führung in Kiew silensky soll sich
mit seinem Oberkommandierenden
zerstritten haben über diese Stadt und
über Strategie und Taktik was bedeutet
das geht es da um verschiedene
Denkschulen
Sky muss vor der Bevölkerung ja
rechtfertigen warum diese Verluste so
hoch sind und ob nicht irgendetwas
unternommen werden kann um das zu
beenden also die Situation finde ich
extrem vergleichbar mit dem asoft
Stahlwerk in mariopol da waren Wochen
lang Monate lang die Kämpfer zum einen
drin da war hat sich aber auch die
Bevölkerung in Sicherheit gebracht
zunächst und es war im Grunde genommen
ein ein Kampf Mario Pulver extrem
aufgeladen war 2014 als der
ostukrainekrieg ausbrach das Symbol das
ist gehalten worden das ist nicht
gefallen die Ukraine haben diese Stadt
verteidigt das ist ein weitaus
aufgeladenes Symbol gewesen als bachmut
jetzt ist bei bachmut ist spielt eine
andere Rolle eine andere Punkt noch eine
große Rolle
bachmut ist auch deshalb dann ein Symbol
weil Russland sie haben es gesagt eine
Kleinstadt nicht erobert bekommt und das
seit Monaten und diese kleinen in dieser
kleinen Stadt genubbeln sich drei Russe
mindestens drei russische Verbände drei
russische Verbände gegen die ukrainische
Armee das ist zum einen die russische
Armee das ist zum anderen die unsägliche
wagnertruppe von Gregorian diesen
wirklich sehr sehr hart kalkulierenden
Mann der zu Tausenden die
Strafgefangenen aus den Lagern geholt
hat und dort als Kanonenfutter
reingegeben hat und der dritte Verbund
das ist der von Verteidigungsminister
schon gut das heißt also Russland mit
dreifachen Verbänden gegen die Ukraine
schafft es nicht und dann aber natürlich
möchte die Ukraine diesen kleinen Sieg
davontragen und es ist nicht nur ein
Sieg ein symbolisches Sieg das ist es
eben nicht bachmut hat Stadt keine
Bedeutung aber die Lage ist sogar
wahnsinnig wichtig es gehen drei
Fernverkehrsstraßen alle stramm in
Richtung Westen das heißt also wenn man
den Donbass weiter erobern möchte muss
man über diese Straßen kommen man muss
über bachmut und deshalb ist es
strategisch schon sehr wichtig schon
wichtig und nicht nur ein Symbol Jürgen
Trittin die Munition haben sie
angesprochen viermal mehr fordert die
Ukraine von den Europäern aber auch
jener Herr berichtigen beklagt sich in
Moskau darüber dass er für seine
Interventionen zu wenig Munition hat wer
weiß eigentlich heute sicher
welche von diesen beiden Seiten das
größere Problem hat
ich glaube das weiß niemand sicher wir
haben heute Berichte gekriegt vom
lettischen geheim Militärgeheimdienst
der beschrieben hat das Russland mit
seinen Vorräten noch zwei Jahren mit
dieser Intensität Krieg führen kann ich
bin bei all diesen Dingen immer sehr
vorsichtig weil wir haben uns in vielen
Fragen dieses Krieges nicht nur wir auch
unsere Dienste und die Bundeswehr und
andere auch geirrt an bestimmten Punkten
ich glaube aber dass die Einschätzung
von der Neumann völlig richtig ist wir
laufen auf einen langen vermobungskrieg
raus der keine großen Gelände Gewinne
haben wird und dieser Zermürbungskrieg
wird letztendlich darüber entschieden
welche Seite am Ende die größere
Durchhaltefähigkeit der das ist nicht
nur eine Frage des Militärs und der
Waffen das ist auch eine Frage der Moral
der politisch sieht man auf der
russischen Seite und das für den bachmut
sehr deutlich
eine zerstrittene Landschaft wenn es
Kritik an Putin gibt die am eigenen Land
fast vollständig verboten ist dann kommt
die eben aus dem Lager der kadyroofs dem
Lager der prigoschins derjenigen die
dort härter vorgehen wollen und auf
diese Weise zeigt sich innerhalb
Russlands zeigen sich Fraktionen die
mögen uns nicht begeistern weil
wahrscheinlich sind die uns noch
unsympathischer aber es muss erstmal
festgestellt werden es gibt dort einen
Streit den Streit innerhalb der
ukrainischen Regierung würde ich nicht
überbewerten ich glaube dass die
Grundhaltung wir wollen nicht dass unser
Land von diesen Russen überhand wird wir
wollen nicht dass es ein großes
Gutschein gibt und das ist ja die
Vorstellung die ist da gibt das ein äh
die ukrainische Führung bei allen
Differenzen sein bevor wir zum Moskau
kommen bleiben wir vielleicht noch meine
Sekunde bei diesen munitionslieferungen
heraus können sie haben gesagt dass die
Europäer da nicht längst viel mehr
geliefert haben ist ein
schwerversagen des Westens ist diese
Munition da und wir haben einfach nur
nicht geliefert oder fangen wir jetzt an
etwas herzustellen was wir in Europa
tatsächlich zu wenig haben ich glaube
wir hätten früher anfangen müssen das zu
bestellen zu produzieren zu produzieren
denn es ist ja keine Überraschung dass
im Krieg Munition verbraucht wird und
man hat ja ungefähr eine Vorstellung
wenn man Waffen liefert wie viel
Munition man dazu liefert sind ja zwei
Typen von Waffen das sind die alten
sowjetischen Waffen die die Ukraine
haben da sind auch die
Produktionsanlagen natürlich
größtenteils in Russland das läuft also
aus und der Westen hat geliefert aber
hat spät geliefert immer gegen
Widerstand wenig geliefert und das macht
das Problem aus und dass man und das
weiß man auch schon länger und man hätte
es schon länger wissen müssen und man
hätte handeln müssen jetzt ist eine im
13 Monat so was festzustellen und zu
beschließen absolut dass man im 13 Monat
dann es ist es ist seit Monaten bekannt
das sagen auch die Ukraine wir sagen das
seit Monaten und übrigens sind das dann
ja nicht Forderungen der Ukraine ich
meine es ist ja es ist
unser Interesse dass sie dem russischen
Angriffskrieg Widerstand leisten das ist
keine Forderungen an uns sondern das ist
das was unser Interesse ausmacht und
jetzt ist diese Knappheit da das wird
jetzt glaube ich kurzfristig dazu führen
dass die relativ wenigen bescheidenen
Vorräte die man noch zurückgehalten hat
jetzt zu einem Teil an die Ukraine gehen
aber man ist hier in einer unglaublichen
und eigentlich unerklärbaren Verzögerung
und einem später handeln und hoffentlich
hoffentlich wird es sich nicht
entscheidend auswirken man kann das
nicht genau wissen wir werden auch
gleich noch mal darüber reden was das
jetzt für Panzer und Flugzeuge bedeutet
und sind jetzt bei der Frage Frau Adler
welche Situation sich da in Moskau
darstellt noch mal zurück auf dieses wer
hat jetzt eigentlich gerade die
schlechteren Karten und das größere
Problem wie wichtig und wie zentral
glauben sie ist das Zerwürfnis in Moskau
zwischen Putin und ja nicht mehr hin äh
schon gut den hat er wieder auf seine
Seite und hat ihn wieder eingestellt
aber die Chef eben rigor in dem Chef der
wagnertruppe und dann
also prigoshi macht etwas ganz
Entscheidendes was Putin nicht freuen
kann er lässt die Armee einfach richtig
schlecht aussehen er ist die ganze Zeit
jedenfalls tut er so ist die ganze Zeit
vor Ort er lässt sich Film im
Jagdflieger er lässt sich wie heute
Filmen angeblich in bachmut vor dem
Denkmal des Großen Vaterländischen
Krieges also er tut so als sei er der
Macher als sei er da und
bewirkt damit dass die Armee immer in
einem bestimmten Zugzwang ist immer so
aussieht als würde sie hinterher klappen
hinterher trotten er ist sozusagen der
der mutige der Vorreiter und zeigt den
anderen jetzt erstmal wo es lang geht
ich glaube allerdings nicht dass
insgesamt man allzu viel
in diesen Streit hinein Geheimnissen
muss das dass sie sich das Streiten an
der obersten Spitze könnte auch ein
Showkampf sein denn es ist das einzige
was irgendwie an Kritik laut wird die
Bevölkerung ist mucksmäuschenstill es
ist niemand auf der Straße ist
protestiert absolut niemand und alle
scheinen ja 80 oder zu 100 Prozent
irgendwie für diesen Krieg es gibt
natürlich auch keine Kriegsbegeisterung
die gibt's ja auch nicht es geht auch
niemand für diesen Krieg auf die Straße
aber um so ein bisschen eine ein
Grummeln und Murmeln da irgendwie
aufzufangen wird eben dieser Streit
jetzt so hochgeht
das ist eine Art Ventil und wenn man
weiß dass man die Gosche in eine ganz
wichtige ich will es gar nicht sagen
Nachrichtenagentur sagen wir eine
Internetplattform nämlich reanovest die
früher war das meine Nachrichtenagentur
heute ist es nicht mehr er ist die ist
ein Sprachrohr und alles das was er tut
und macht wird über Ria Novus die
rausgeblasen das heißt also das ist doch
gewollt das ganze das macht ja doch
nicht gegen den Pressedienst des Kreml
gegen pescov gegen Putin das können wir
doch nicht im Ernst glauben also da
findet wirklich auch ein Schaukampf
statt der ablenken soll und der ein
bisschen was absorbiert was ich so an
Unmut aufgesammelt hat interessante
These Felix Lee sitzt links von ihnen
geschätzter Kollege lange in Peking für
die tats arbeiten und natürlich als
Journalist unterwegs die USA Felix Lee
Verdächtigen die Chinesen seit neuestem
Waffen an Russland zu liefern tun sie
das wollen sie das tun ist es an dem
also zumindest haben die USA keine
handfesten Beweise vorgelegt und so
lange das nicht passiert und ich finde
das ist schon ein harter vorwo da ist
die USA verpflichtet diese Beweise auch
Kollegen es macht aus chinesischer Sicht
in der chinesischen Logik auch keinen
Sinn also pro russische Neutralität wie
auch Experten das bezeichnen wie China
agiert das trifft es schon ganz gut also
pro russisch verbal sich für Russland
einzusetzen aber doch sich nicht in den
Krieg aktiv hineinziehen zu lassen das
ist schon die Leitlinie die von Peking
ausgeht und
um das vielleicht mal auch zu erläutern
was dahinter steckt also wir haben ja so
ein bisschen so den Verdacht äh China
versucht Nutzen zu ziehen ja tut es auch
aus diesem Konflikt aber so einfach und
eindeutig ist es in China halt auch
nicht also ich glaube Putin und dieser
ganze Konflikt bereitet Peking auch
großes Kopfzerbrechen ja China fühlt
sich insgesamt jetzt unabhängig von dem
Ukraine Krieg von den USA in die Ecke
gedrängt
die wollen p ich will um jeden Preis
Putin irgendwie halten und befürchtet
dass dieser doch ziemlich missling
lungener Krieg Putin immer schwächer
aussehen lässt weil sie befürchten zwei
Szenarien also das nach Putin entweder
eine pro westliche Regierung an die
Macht kommt dann wäre China auf einmal
isoliert das will China nicht es gibt
aber andererseits auch die Befürchtung
dass es dann halt ein Mafiosi aus der
wagnergruppe an die Macht kommt das
schafft auch unglaubliche Unsicherheit
also da teilt China eine zu lange Grenze
mit Russland als dass man einen so
unberechnenden waren Nachbarn haben will
und in diesem Dilemma befindet sich
Peking also deswegen auch diese
Friedensinitiative die wir so ein
bisschen belächeln die ist schlecht
keine Frage weil die da stecken
überhaupt keine konkreten Vorschläge
hinten drin wie man zu mehr Frieden
kommen kann
ja aber sehr sehr allgemein gehalten und
ja es sind pro russische Anklänge
definitiv zu sehen aber letztendlich ist
es doch auch ein Versuch vielleicht auf
einer ungeschickten Weise von Peking
Pekings auch noch nicht besonders
erfahren das muss man auch sagen
ist ein Versuch durchaus das ist nicht
noch mehr eskaliert weil das ist die
große Angst die auch China hat und man
muss noch mal sagen dass auch die
Ukraine nicht bestätigen dass es
Waffenlieferungen aus China in Richtung
Russland gibt also da kommen wir jetzt
dann vielleicht auch noch mal zu den
besonderen Interessen der Russen und in
Entschuldigung der USA und könnten uns
noch mal die Frage stellen und müssen
uns noch mal die Frage stellen was wir
eigentlich peter Neumann von den
Ukrainern wissen könnten und es aber
nicht erfahren erstaunlicherweise werden
über den britischen und den
US-amerikanischen Geheimdienst
regelmäßig um nicht zu sagen sogar
täglich Informationen über die
russischen Verluste veröffentlicht aber
Gefahren relativ wenig darüber wie es
eigentlich bei den Ukrainern ausschaut
noch mal die Frage
welche Seite hat gerade das größere
Problem was wissen wir über die Verluste
der Ukraine die Situation der Ukrainer
sowohl in Bezug auf das Material aber
auch in Bezug auf die Soldaten
beispielsweise nicht besonders viel so
die Militärexperten sagen dass so die
Verluste so eins zu fünf eins zu sechs
im Vergleich zu den Russen sind was
erstmal ziemlich positiv klingt aus
ukrainischer Seite aber natürlich muss
man berücksichtigen dass die Ukraine
ungefähr ein Fünftel von Russland ist
also insofern macht das schon aus Sinn
ich wollte noch eine Sache zu zur
Situation in China sagen weil ich
nämlich da eine gewisse Änderung
beobachtet habe also am Anfang des
Konflikt vor ungefähr einem Jahr war es
so dass China durchaus dieses Argument
das hier die Souveränität eines Landes
verletzt wurde
dass das durchaus ernst genommen wurde
und deswegen haben ja die Chinesen in
den Vereinten Nationen auch mit einer
Enthaltung gestimmt am Anfang
aber was ich gemerkt habe besonders bei
der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz wo ich
mich mit verschiedenen
Regierungsvertretern aus China
unterhalten habe ist dass sich die sage
ich mal das Framing so ein bisschen
geändert hat und dass man immer mehr
argumentiert ja die Ukraine das ist im
Prinzip ein abtrünniges Territorium so
wie Taiwan ein abtrünniges Territorium
von China ist ich glaube dass man im
Laufe dieses Jahres immer mehr auch auf
die russische Sicht eingeschwenkt ist
und sagt die Ukraine das ist nicht
wirklich ein souveränes Territorium das
ist ein Territorium dass sich die Russen
zurückholen und das ist natürlich sehr
bedenklich die stimme zu dass die Russen
keine Eskalation wollen sie wollen keine
Atom kriegen die die Chinesen wollen
kein atomkriegen aber dass sie im Laufe
dieses Jahres durchaus
in Richtung der russischen Position
gerückt das ist hochinteressant dass sie
das Sagen und wir können ja super gerne
auch an dieser Stelle schon diskutieren
das heißt im Grunde ja aber dass man im
Grunde sagt wenn man sich verhält wie
bei der Ukraine müsste dann China ja
auch mit einer Reaktion des Westens wie
in der Ukraine rechnen also die
Situation heute müsste ja die Chinesen
gegebenenfalls auch beunruhigen und eher
unwahrscheinlich machen dass sie genau
wie der besten die Ukraine verteidigt
hat dann Teil waren angreifen wenn die
USA schon gesagt haben das ist unsere
deswegen ist es so wichtig deswegen ist
es auch aus diesem Gesichtspunkt so
wichtig dass man die Ukraine unterstützt
aber ein weiterer Punkt der von den
Chinesen sehr häufig gemacht wurde in
meinen Gesprächen ist glaube ich ein
wichtiger der der in der westlichen
Diskussion nicht so häufig vorkommt oder
zumindest abstrakt vorkommt aber nicht
praktisch und zwar der Punkt ist Putin
kann es sich nicht leisten zu verlieren
Putin kann es sich nicht leisten zu
verlieren und das
informiert dann die Einstellung dass man
sagt ja
klar natürlich die Situation in der
Ukraine ist schwierig aber die Russen
dann nicht so einfach aufgeben die
werden weitermachen bei putinessig nicht
leisten kann diesen Krieg zu verlieren
und deswegen glaube ich dass daraus auch
die Situation kommt wo man sagt wir sind
eher auf der Seite Russlands als auf der
Seite
also Chinas Position zu diesem Krieg hat
natürlich sehr sehr viel mit dem zu tun
mit dem Konflikt in China mit den USA
führt und hat und äh also die USA drängt
China inzwischen gerade zu in eine Ecke
die ich inzwischen für doch gefährlich
halte also
so klug und erfahren ich Joe bidenhalte
und es so richtig finde dass man auch
China in allen möglichen Fragen durchaus
auch Grenzen setzt hart verhandelt und
so weiter was die Chinesen im übrigen ja
auch tun
so gefährlich halte ich es dass Joe
Biden die Stimmung oder das fortsetzt
was sein Vorgänger auch schon getan hat
nämlich eine geradezu antichinesische
Stimmung im Land zu schaffen in den USA
was hin nicht mehr nur an diesen
konkreten Punkten sich festmachen an den
Streitpunkten sondern bis hin zu offener
Feindschaften und die wollen im Grunde
auch für unmöglichen dass China ein
Vermittler in diesem Krieg sein könnte
also jetzt im Krieg der Ukraine sein
könnte naja das weiß ich nicht so genau
wie das in Washington gesehen wird
dieser Punkte Friedmann ich glaube die
nimmt man da einfach nicht ernst aber
insgesamt diese Haltung oder diese
Tendenz in den USA China zum Hauptfeind
zu machen die halt die für gefährlich
also so
schwierig China in vielen Fragen ist man
mit China auch hart umgeben muss so eine
offene Feindschaft also da glaube finde
ich ist archina inzwischen ein doch zu
großer wichtiger aktuell in allen
möglichen globalen Fragen dass man so
ein schwarz-weiß Bild tut tun nicht
vermeiden sollte und das erklärt
wiederum natürlich die chinesische
Haltung auch im Laufe der Zeit also die
das Wording in China inzwischen ist ja
die Ukraine oder alles diese von der
Orangenen Revolution bis hin zu allem
was da passiert ist das ist ein Produkt
von dem war aus dem was die USA
angezettelt haben also deswegen das ist
dann so ein bisschen das würdigen warum
man nicht warum man mit Putin durchaus
in Kontakt tritt warum man mit dem
belarussischen Präsidenten in Kontakt
tritt aber noch in Kontakt getreten ist
weil der ja ohnehin eine Marionette ist
was China letztendlich fordert in diesem
Konflikt ist dass die USA eins zu eins
verhandelt und das sind Punkte also so
absurd das aus in unseren Ohren klingen
mag aber ich glaube das sind
Ansatzpunkte wo wir vielleicht genauer
hinschauen könnten wo es wirklich
vielleicht doch Ansätze gibt da auch
anzusetzen also da auch strategischer zu
überlegen wie man mit China umgeht um so
durchaus diesen ich bin nicht zu
optimistisch aber diesen leichten Ansatz
von Peking da Bewegung in
Friedensverhandlungen in Richtung
Frieden zu machen also dass der Westen
das durchaus aufgreift weil man muss
auch sagen mehr gibt es interessant
vielleicht können wir dazu die Politiker
noch mal hören weil interessant war ja
auch ihre Bemerkung man wünscht sich den
Sturz von Putin aber offensichtlich hier
in der westlichen Welt aber man wünscht
Ihnen sich in China nicht weil man sich
ausmalt das anstelle dessen eben ein
Herr Gregorian kommen könnte oder aus
chinesischer sich noch schlimmer äh eine
westeuropäische Regierung aber auf jeden
Fall sind Sie an einer Sicherheit
offensichtlich interessiert vielleicht
kann man so formulieren
also zunächst mal aus Sicht der USA ist
China der Herausforderer nicht Putin
sondern der Herausforderung und auf
Amerika genauso ist es amerikanischer
man kann das macht Stellung umfassend
das ist China und ich Putin und das
waren eigentlich die Prioritäten von Joe
Biden in der Außenpolitik man konnte es
an einem Tiefpunkt nämlich Afghanistan
sehen
so ist es und die Menschen dort erleben
es jeden Tag die Frauen zuallererst das
war auch für den das hat der Trump alles
sozusagen eingebrockt mit aber es war
dann auch vollendet und nicht
notwendigerweise vollendet hätte Vorfall
endet werden müssen durch Joe Biden als
Ausdruck einer neuen außenpolitischen
Priorität und das ist nicht Europa und
seine Umgebung sondern das ist China und
deswegen war es auch Unsinn oder ist
auch diese Theorie Unsinn das Amerika
diesen Konflikt mit der Ukraine
angezettet ist ja weil Priorität von
Anfang an von beiden bei China und der
ist ins Amt gekommen und wollte China
genau das ist das ist
immer sagen darf ich finde dass man ich
glaube nicht dass China als Vermittler
taucht dafür sind sie zu sehr Partei
aber ich finde dennoch dass man aus
diesem Papier zwei Elemente nehmen kann
und ich finde das sollte man China ernst
nehmen das eine ist die Ziffer 11 da
steht drin wir wollen nicht dass die
Lieferketten durch einen langanhaltenden
Konflikt weiter gestört für eine sage
ich ja bitte was tut ihr dafür und das
ist andere ist jene Ziffer wo sie ganz
tagesaktuell an dieser Stelle gesagt
haben sie wollen sich ernsthafte für
einsetzen dass die Vorstellung der
internationalenergiebehörde zur
Demilitarisierung der Region um
saporisha umgesetzt werden und ich finde
an diesem Anspruch also jetzt gar nicht
an dem großen an diesem Anspruch sollten
wir die Chinesen wirklich hart dran
nehmen und sagen hier dann macht man
dann sorgt dafür dass das was grossi
vereinbart hat und der ist ja noch nicht
frei von den Russen wer die
Zusammensetzung der iaio kennt weiß
welchen Einfluss Russland in dieser
Organisation hat jetzt macht das mal
also ich bin dafür mit den Chinesen hart
aber pragmatisch und sind sich nicht zu
glauben sie sein vermittelt das sind sie
nicht und da würden wir andere in der
Welt einfallen aber an dieser Stelle
zusammen
wissen wollt dass dieser Krieg nicht
endlos geht ihr wollt dass die
Auswirkungen dieses Krieges beendet
werden oder gemindert werden dann bitte
setzt das um was sie sagt nutzt euren
Einfluss in Moskau dafür zu sorgen dass
es beispielsweise zu einer
entmeditarisierung aber wolfgang hat das
letzte Sendung bei uns auch
vorgeschlagen darüber nicht hinweg zu
gehen und zu sagen das könnte genau ein
Punkt sein wo man die Chinesen eben auch
mit in die Verantwortung nimmt weil das
versuchen wir uns vorzustellen und
auszumalen peter Neumann am Ende dieser
Krieg eben in einem Friedensschluss
enden wird und muss hoffentlich also in
Verhandlungen die für beide Seiten
wahrscheinlich schmerzhaft sein werden
und wer wird da sitzen werden da nicht
die Ukraine und Russland sitzen und die
USA und China also ich glaube
ich glaube das ist eine eine eine
ich weiß nicht ob China da sitzen wird
aber ich glaube das ist in Deutschland
eine populäre Meinung oder eine die
selten geäußert wird wir haben in
Deutschland zwei Camps die einen die
wollen den totalen Sieg der Ukraine die
anderen die wollen im Prinzip
zurückziehen und das Russland gewinnen
hört auf euch zu wehren gut ich glaube
ich bin auf der Seite von Präsident
macron der gesagt hat wir müssen die
Ukraine militärisch unterstützen um sie
in die Lage zu versetzen am Ende eines
wahrscheinlich langen abnutzungskrieges
am Verhandlungstisch ein gutes Ergebnis
zu erreichen und das ist glaube ich das
wahrscheinlichste Szenario wir werden
keinen großen Durchbruch sehen auf der
russischen Seite oder auf der
ukrainischen Seite wir werden
wahrscheinlich das ist meine Voraussage
meine Prognose diese Situation diese
frontverläufe die wir momentan sehen
wahrscheinlich einige Zeit noch sehen
und irgendwann kommen wir an den Punkt
wo wie der große Politikwissenschaftler
Mann gesagt hat wo ein schmerzhaftes
Patt existiert wo beide Seiten das
Gefühl haben wir können militärisch
nicht mehr so viel erreichen wie am
Verhandlungstisch dann kommt die
Verhandlung und dann wird möglicherweise
zwei Jahre haben wir vorhin schon
gesehen
ob das so kommt ja wissen wir natürlich
nicht kann alles passieren das ist nicht
mein Punkt es hängt von uns ab es hängt
vom Westen ab wenn ich natürlich von
vorne rein die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine so skaliere
dass die Formel sich bewahrheiten soll
Russland darf nicht gewinnen und die
Ukraine nicht verlieren also wenn ich
von vornherein die Formen vorgebe es
sollte so einem Part kommen nein wenn
ich wie man pro jetzt schon nein aber
der deutsche Bundeskanzler machen
also wenn ich das so mache und wenn ich
die unter die Ukraine nicht so
unterstütze wie es möglich wäre dann ist
auch meine Prognose wird es in einem
ganz lange dauernden fürchterlichen
wechselseitigen Vernichtungskrieg führen
das glaube ich denn bevor die Situation
dann oder wann dann die Situation da ist
das ist zu einem Verhandlungsprozess
kommt den sehe ich dann gar nicht und
darum hängt es an uns am besten und an
dem Ausmaß der Unterstützung der Ukraine
wie lange es dauert bis wieder
diplomatische
ich würde gerne noch mal zurückkommen
auf die Rolle Chinas weil ein Punkt noch
erwähnenswert wäre nämlich die Reaktion
von selensky auf diesen 12 Punkte
Friedensplan der Chinesen der war nicht
also begeistert würde ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt sagen aber er hat den auf gar
keinen Fall sofort zurückgewiesen und er
hat gesagt nicht schlecht nicht schlecht
begeistert so ne also er war im Grunde
genommen
ich habe ihn ich habe ihn so verstanden
man kann da zusammenkommen und ich finde
auch diese pragmatischen Überlegungen in
welchen Punkten könnte man das es wird
sowieso nicht diesen einen Verhandler
geben es wird nicht diesen einen
vermitteln geben es wird Erdogan geben
der mit beiden Seiten zu beiden Seiten
problematisches Verhältnis hat zu beiden
Seiten aber auch ein ganz produktives
Verhältnis hat endlich kann es bei China
sein China ist im für die Ukraine auch
kein unbekanntes Restaurant und
unbekannt umgekehrt auch nicht auch die
Ukraine ist für China interessant
gewesen es hat vor dem Krieg eine Reihe
von wirtschaftlichen großen Interessen
gegeben da ging es um Rohstoffe es ging
um seltene Erden und so weiter und es
ging aber auch vor allem um diese großen
Agrarflächen die die Ukraine hat die die
für die Chinesen extrem interessant sind
also man kennt die Chinesen man hat sie
reingelassen man wollte man wollte
Geschäfte machen mit ihnen und das ging
sogar so weit dass die Ukraine gesagt
haben Vorsicht wir uns droht hier der
ausverkauft dazu kam es da nicht da kam
was anderes schreckliches aber das ist
sozusagen auch ein Anknüpfungspunkt den
man ja durchaus mal
benutzen kann
ich bin bei Herrn Neumann und dem
wertschätzen wissen was man gesagt hat
ich wollte noch einen Punkt hinweisen
der vielleicht nicht ganz unwichtig ist
und vielleicht ist das Jenseits auch der
deutschen de wenn ich die Signale sehe
die aus der US-Administration selber
gestreut werden parallel zu den lauten
reden es long as a takes in München sind
das alles Signale die sagen wir werden
das jetzt noch eine Weile unterstützen
aber wir sehen sehr genau dass wir auf
einen Präsidentschaftswahlkampf zulaufen
und deswegen ist diese Frage der
Unterstützung und auch der Limitierung
die da drin steckt eine
seriös nein nein ich bin ja nur dafür
dass man jetzt als auf deutscher Seite
oder auf europäischer Seite diese diese
Frage sehr ernsthaft mit ins Kalkül
zieht das heißt nämlich zwei Jahre
erstens es kann sein dass es Druck aus
den USA gibt also so abzuschließ
beschrieben haben es heißt aber vor
allen Dingen dass in einer solchen die
Nase die
Sicherheitsgarantien militärisch
politisch und ökonomisch für die Ukraine
von Europa geliefert werden müssen und
ich will das eine Diskussion die kommt
bei uns manchmal ein bisschen kurz die
kommt nicht zu kurz darüber ja letzte
Woche schon wieder und es gibt eine
Geschichte die haben wir dem Wall Street
Journal zu verdanken nämlich eine
Spekulation darüber ob sogar Herr macron
und Herr Scholz gemeinsam mit Herrn
silensky schon über einen früheren
Ausstieg aus den Waffen gesprochen
Kriegsmüdigkeit oder Realpolitik
so lange wie nötig ist der Slogan für
die Unterstützung Kiews doch laut Wall
Street journey gibt es in London Paris
und Berlin erster Anzeichen für ein
Ablaufdatum
Anfang Februar sollen es macron und
Scholze lensky signalisiert haben ein
Zeitfenster für Rückeroberungen bisher
Herbst
dann seit Zeit für Verhandlungen mit
Moskau
haben Sie davon schon gehört was
vermuten sie darüber denken sie dass uns
genauso die Luft ausgeht wie den
Amerikanern weil im Herbst genau wie Sie
es sagen gibt es Präsidentschaftswahlen
ich glaube eher dass wir in einer
Situation sind und so farbig dieses
Argument mit dem Herbst immer für mich
verwendet all diejenigen die jetzt
friedensverhandlung gefolgt haben gesagt
das wird nichts vorher Herbst weil
nämlich erstmal diese jeweiligen
offensiven die die Russen vorbereiten
die die Ukrainer vorbereitet es hört
sich gut brutal an aber es ist ja auch
brutal ausgekämpft werden müssen erst
dann wird man überhaupt eine Übersicht
darüber haben wie das an dieser Stelle
möglicherweise
nähert man sich diesem
Erschöpfungszustand dass dahinter ein
grandioser Plan steckt also wenn ich
allein die Elemente sehe der
entstandsetzung von alten Leopard
verbessern der Aufbau von
rüstungskapazitäten innerhalb der
Europäischen Union Europas
ich meine das was als Deutschland noch
aus den alten Beständen kommt das was an
neuen
munitionsproduktionslinien jetzt
aufgebaut werden soll auf der Basis des
der EDA das sind alles Dinge die weit
über den Herbst hinausragen und übrigens
hinausweis müssen weil es diese
Sicherheitsgarantien
entschuldigung wenn ich das nochmal
Frage dann geht es um
Sicherheitsinteressen und dann geht es
aber eigentlich um die Hoffnung dass wir
eben nicht noch einen zweijährigen
abnutzungskrieg vor uns haben sondern
ich ich wer vorsichtig das wissen wir
nicht ich finde aber dass man sich auf
diesen Zustand vorbeugen deswegen finde
ich z.B die Überlegung die
Herausforderungen gemacht hat was wie
könnte man sowas wie
Sicherheitsgarantien durch Buchstaben
alles Dinge über die wir uns jetzt
Gedanken machen müssen damit wir nicht
wieder hinterher
der Grund und ist ein wichtiger Faktor
den ich auch noch
hinzufügen wollte zu dem was Herr
Röttgen gesagt hat der Grund weshalb per
macron den Vorschlag gemacht
ist doch dass es um zwei strategische
imperative geht es geht zum einen darum
die Ukraine zu unterstützen so viel von
ihrem Territorium zurück zur erobern wie
möglich um ein Signal auch an potent zu
senden dass das nicht geht das
Aggression bestraft wird dass er nicht
andere Projekte in Angriff nehmen kann
aber gleichzeitig und das macht die
Situation sehr ja so schwierig ist das
Ziel von Herrn macron und ich glaube
auch von Herrn Scholz und anderen zu
sagen vielleicht auch von Herrn beiden
zu vermeiden dass eine Situation
entsteht die zu einem Zerfall Russland
führt eine strategische Situation zu
schaffen die nicht dazu führt dass
Russland im Chaos versinkt weil die
strategischen Konsequenzen für Europa
und den Westen dieser Situation werden
mindestens genauso groß wie die eines
also weitergehenden Konfliktes
strategische Dilemma es ist einfach zu
sagen wir wollen die Ukraine gewinnt wir
wollen dass Sie alles zurückerobern aber
wie verhindert man gleichzeitig das in
Russland ein solches Chaos entsteht dass
uns in allerlei Hinsicht aber dazu
müsste es ja zu einem Chaos kommen
können in Russland und es kommt dann zu
einem Chaos wenn es wieder streitende
kräftig gibt es ist im Moment überhaupt
nicht zu sehen dass in den Regionen
große Gegenkräfte zum Beispiel auf Putin
wirken die sind ja gar nicht da also
diese wird diese Prophezeiung die da an
die Wand gemalt wird ich sehe überhaupt
ich sehe keine Unterfütterung dafür
aber mir sagt jeder Russland mit dem ich
sprechen kann ein ein ein ein ein eine
Niederlage in diesem Krieg nicht
überleben wollen
dazu muss es doch Kräfte geben die
darauf sehr genau schauen und darauf
warten und auf ihre auf ihre Chance
warten und sie dann ergreifen diese
Kräfte sind nicht zu sehen es gibt keine
Opposition Funktion die Opposition ist
außer Landes es gibt keine
Regionalfürsten die so stark sind dass
sie sagen oh jetzt gucken wir mal was im
Creme passiert dann sind wir aber mal
eine Reihe oder hüpfen wir da rein die
sind nicht sichtbar und das was sich tut
zwischen pregorian Scholl GU und Putin
da sind das sind drei Freunde das dürfen
wir nicht vergessen ist ein ganz ganz
leichter Komfort Kumpane von von von
Putin scheu ist derjenige das ist der
Vertraute mit dem Urlaub macht also dass
du dass die Machtkämpfe zwischen den
dreien ausgetragen werden
vergessen sie ist das glaube ich
überhaupt nicht es gibt andere Kräfte es
gibt jemanden der komplett von der
Bildfläche verschwunden ist und ein
großer gestritten Tier ist ein großer
politikstratege ist das ist so Kopf der
ist weg der ist abgesetzt worden er
wollte gehen er ist abgesetzt worden und
der könnte sein dass er sich warm läuft
aber hat er wirklich Massen hinter sich
er hat es verstanden Parteien zu gründen
das hat er gemacht aber ich sehe diese
widerstreitenden Partei diese ganzen
Parteien in der Duma sind alles pro
putin-parteien alle künstlich geschaffen
also diese Gegengewichte sehe ich nicht
wir haben ein großes taktisches
unstrategisches Problem heraus noch mal
ich mich glaube präzise zu erinnern dass
auch Joe Biden sagte wir möchten die
Ukraine wieder befähigen noch
ermächtigen russisches Territorium
anzugreifen das ist ein Wortbeitrag aus
der New York Times gewesen von vor gut
einem Jahr glaube ich ähm knapp einem
Jahr so also wir haben im Grunde eine
Erklärung des Westens dass die Ukraine
sich auf ukrainischen Territorium
verteidigen darf aber nie auch
strategische Ziele in Russland angreifen
darf das
stimmt ist aber etwas anderes als Herr
Neumann gesagt hat das bedeutet nur
eigentlich ist das nur Zumutung
Russland wird von russischen Ukraine
wird von russischen territoren
angegriffen darf aber sich darf aber die
Stellung nicht beschießen von denen sie
angegriffen werden weil unsere oberste
Maxime neben der Unterstützung ist wir
tun nicht Ausbreitung keine Ausweitung
das wäre dann ja möglicher in
amerikanischer eine nato-waffe mit der
zurückgeschossen wurde auf russisches
Territorium das ist also sehr sehr
extrem weitgehend ich halte es für
richtig weil diese rote Linie das ist
keine Ausweitung dieses Krieges gibt
eine Überlebensfrage auch ist aber der
Punkt der entscheidende Punkt den hatte
Herr Neumann schon angesprochen wenn ein
Staat mit 140 Teilnehmer
ja genau nein noch tiefer liegt noch die
Frage was ist eigentlich unser
strategisches Ziel richtig was ist
eigentlich
strategische Ziel ist wahrscheinlich
fortgeschritten aber das ist die die
Frage die wir eigentlich kaum
diskutieren und es gibt doch einen
verdeckten Streit ja es gibt diejenigen
die sagen es geht um die Ukraine aber es
geht auch um die Zukunft Russlands und
dann gibt es auch diejenigen die machen
sich jetzt schon Sorge und um die
Zukunft Russlands und dass das Land
nicht zerfällt und das ist da irgendwie
mit Putin geordnet weitergeht nein das
heißt ein bisschen Problem also dass die
machen sich hin das ist sozusagen das
ist eine Politik die hat eine bestimmte
das eine das ist eine Unterstützung der
Ukraine die die auch Russland politische
Ziele verfolgt das ist meine
Unterstellung warum der Bundeskanzler
sich so verhält wie er sich verhält ich
halte das für falsch nach meiner
Überzeugung gibt es ein Ziel und das ist
Frieden in Europa wenn Putin auch nur zu
einem gewissen Teil mit der Methode
Krieg Erfolg hat dann werden wir in
Europa diesen Krieg nicht mehr los und
darum muss das oberste Ziel sein nicht
wie ist die innere Situation Russlands
sondern das oberste Ziel muss sein dass
Russland versteht
das Russland versteht das
Problem
Russland darf diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen sonst wird es belohnt und auch
Russland muss verstehen dass auch für
Russland kein Kolonialismus und
Imperialismus mehr eine Möglichkeit
sagen das müssen Sie verstehen genau sie
müssen noch einmal erklären wohin Sie
wollen Herr Neumann wir sind vor welcher
Strategie vor welchem strategischen die
Lämmer eigentlich haben sie schon
genannt
habe ich versucht zu erklären also wir
müssen eine Situation hinbekommen
wo
Putin versteht dass sich diese
Aggression nicht lohnt aber wie wir
gleichzeitig eine Situation vermeiden in
der Russland zerfällt und ich kann es
halt ich kann ich kann das absolut
verstehen wir sind wir haben alle keine
keine Kristallkugel wir wissen alle
nicht was die Zukunft besagt ich
unterhalte mich mit sehr vielen
russland-experten 2030 Jahre in Russland
die sagen alle das Russland eine
Niederlage eine Art die Art von
Niederlage die Herr Röttgen anschreibt
nicht überleben würde und da muss man
sich als Strategie natürlich da muss man
sich Gedanken darüber machen was
passiert dann was ist die Konsequenz
dessen und ich glaube dass das etwas ist
was nicht ausreichend diskutiert wird
und worüber man sich
das Land sein das koloniale Ansprüche
erleben darf
so verstanden dass er sehr bewusst aus
einem europäischen Sicherheitsargument
argumentiert hat
nämlich nicht nee nee der Russe darf mit
seinem Kolonialismus sein Imperialismus
nicht durchkommen aber es ist auch und
das ist das der andere Teil habe ich ihn
verstanden okay der andere Teil der
Sicherheit des sicherheitspolitischen
Dilemmas eine zerfallenes Russland kann
für die Sicherheit Europas ein
erheblichen genauso bedeutsam und das
ist das ist eine Erfahrung die wir
übrigens zum Beispiel in bestimmten
anderen benachbarten Regionen wo wir wo
andere nicht wir und mit großer selbst
Gewissheit
das ist genau das ist jetzt ich
Unterricht ich wollte nur nicht dass er
falsch aber das ist richtig aber
trotzdem eine Kontinuität der Russland
Politik jetzt unter Veränderung der
Erfahrung des Krieges die vorher doch
doch die schon vorgemacht wurde warum
durfte die Ukraine keine Waffen haben
warum dürfen die keine Waffen haben
Russland könnte es missverstehen
Russland führen warum darf denn die
Ukraine warum darf Polen nicht nach der
Mitglied werden weil Russland sich
bedroht fühlt das ist immer immer
berücksichtigen Rücksicht auf Russland
nehmen
weil Sicherheit in Europa gibt es nicht
zu der Pipeline kommen Russland nehmen
wegen der Geographie bei Russland da ist
weil Russland ein großes Land ist nicht
weggehen und unsere Sicherheit und und
unser Sicherheit
ehrlich gesagt vielleicht kann man
diesen Gedanken noch mal kurz wegen
können wir darüber auch nicht so laut in
der Öffentlichkeit sprechen weil es auch
eine Gefahr darstellt wenn wir dieses
strategische Ziel ausmalen um auf diese
Sicherheitsrisiko abzuheben und damit ja
gleichzeitig auch einen Putin ein
deutliches Zeichen geben würden was eben
unsere roten Linien sind und deswegen
auch verstehe ich das auch vom Herbert
drin das sagt ja ich bin ja kein
Politiker also ich kann ja offen
sprechen
die Öffentlichkeit mobilisieren aber ich
sage als jemand der über diese Situation
strategisch nachdenkt dass natürlich
auch in
Szenario der dass das hier manchmal
beschrieben wird das ja letztlich in
letzter Konsequenz auch auf
Regimewechsel hinausläuft mit dem wir ja
in den letzten 20 Jahren keine besonders
guten Erfahrungen gemacht haben dass da
auch Gefahren drin liegt
Forscher hier schon zu sitzen gehabt die
alle gesagt haben es ist wichtig dass
wir sie an irgendeinem Zeitpunkt an den
Tisch bekommen dass wir Russland
versuchen mit irgendeinem
Sicherheitsinteresse dass die Russen
haben an den Tisch bekommen
das ist klar
doch noch mal ganz kurz Entschuldigung
warum ich Frau Adler
Bemerkung unterstütze dass ähm und zwar
ist es wir haben ein sehr
ordentistischen westlichen Blick und ähm
wir reden über China wir reden aber auch
über viele andere Länder des globalen
Südens die jetzt alle lauern die eine
eine eine die die gesamte Weltordnung in
wandeln gesehen und zum Beispiel china
ist ein aktuell der überhaupt wie ich
das auch schon erwähnte überhaupt nicht
das Interesse hat das ein putin-regime
stört und die werden das mit allen
Mitteln auch versuchen zu machen auf
ihrer Weise auf wirtschaftliche Weise
die westlichen Unternehmen haben sich
auch von Russland verabschiedet da sind
chinesische Unternehmen dort selbst wenn
es mal kein Krieg mehr mit der Ukraine
gehen wird sind die Chinesen dort
hingekommen um zu bleiben die werden das
System dort mit allen ihren Kräften
stabilisieren es gibt andere Länder wir
reden von plötzlich solchen Akteuren wie
Südafrika Brasilien die spielen
vielleicht jetzt alles noch keine große
zentrale Rolle aber sie teilen überhaupt
überhaupt nicht die Perspektive des
Westens sie sehen dass da sie sagen zum
einen das haben auch enttäuscht sie sind
in Deutschland
Krieg warum müssen wir da reingezogen
sind wir finden das jetzt auch nicht
toll was Russland da macht aber eure
Sanktion zu unterstützen nee das machen
wir nicht
Indien wie China rein die sich dann
china hat dieses friedenspapier zudem
auch geäußert publiziert aus dem Grund
sich als gewissermaßen als Sprachrohr
des globalen Südens zu präsentieren ob
das funktioniert
aber ich glaube es wird von vielen
Menschen auch in anderen Ländern
durchaus diese Sicht geteilt dass nur
weil der Westen jetzt will irgendwie
eine uneingeschränkte die Digitalität
einzufordern dass alle dann dem zu
folgen haben die das machen wir nicht
alle der besten genau diese Länder
wahrscheinlich auch zu häufig enttäuscht
in der Geschichte wir müssen eine ganz
schnelle Runde machen zur Pipeline sorry
wir schaffen das weil wir haben schlaue
gestern an diesem Tisch Jürgen Trittin
fängt an wie
Zusammenhänge sind schnell erzählt es
gibt neue Informationen neue
Spekulationen darüber wer die
Anschlagsserie auf beide Nord Stream
Pipelines verursacht haben könnte
geplant haben könnte über sechs Menschen
wird spekuliert über den Rostocker Hafen
wird spekuliert wir hätten eigentlich
noch ein Stückchen dazu gezeigt aber sie
haben das in den Nachrichten gestern
verfolgt was glauben sie ist da dran
das muss ermittelt werden das ganz
einfach wir haben es mit einem Terrorakt
zu tun wir haben es mit einem
schwerwiegenden terroristischen Akt zu
tun der ist mit Material durchgeführt
worden wo zumindest die Verdacht dass es
staatliche Beteiligung gegeben mittelbar
oder unmittelbar gegeben haben muss sehr
naheliegend ist deswegen klärt der
Generalbundesanwalt das auf es gibt
geheimdienstliche Erkenntnisse die uns
nicht vollständig offenbart worden sind
sondern Hinweise an dieser Stelle nein
nein
an dieser Stelle aber ich finde schon
was die schwere dieses Delikt hat es
verdient das ist sorgfältig aufgeklärt
wird und es nützt überhaupt nichts darum
Spekulation zu machen weil für jede
Spekulation gibt es genauso viel zu
Hause wievielten wie für das Gegenteil
also wenn sie jetzt alle diesen Satz
sagen können wir uns die Runde sparen
ich glaube wir haben mit diesen
Einzelheiten die wir jetzt erfahren
haben wie diese Pipeline gesprengt
worden ist eigentlich nichts Neues
erfahren ich wirklich was Neues es gibt
absolut keinen Beweis für die immer
wieder vorgebrachte Behauptung in diesen
sogenannten Recherchen oder auch
wirklich Recherchen dass die Ukraine
daran beteiligt ist es ist jetzt die
letzte Spekulation
es könnte aus amerikanischen Stuben
kommen jetzt gibt sie Spekulation das
ist jetzt
deswegen war aber in Richtung Ukraine
und der Beweis sind zwei gefälschte
Pässe und eine Firma in Polen die in
ukrainischer Hand ist ich finde wenn man
sich das Datum anschaut nämlich 26
September an dem die pipels in die Luft
gesprengt wurden da hatten wir acht
Monate Krieg und oder sieben Monate
Krieg und wir hatten die Unterstützung
des Westens Deutschlands der
Europäischen Union der NATO der der USA
und so weiter es macht überhaupt die
Ukraine hatte alle Unterstützung und sie
hätte sich durch einen solchen Anschlag
diese Unterstützung zumindest gefährdet
ob sie auch zu Ende gewesen wäre weiß
man nicht und deshalb kommt dieses Motiv
für meine Begriffe überhaupt nicht in
Frage ist sei denn das gibt es natürlich
auch es gibt natürlich auch okay Russ
sie sehen ist mir nach was wäre wenn
Herr Röttgen wie sehr wenn es eine
ukrainische pro-ukrainische Gruppe
gewesen wäre wie was würde das für die
öffentliche Reaktion im Westen bedeuten
der es wurde das bedeuten was Frau Adler
gesagt hat was aber mich dem Argument
anschließen lässt dass das ich halt das
klingt für mich überhaupt nicht
plausibel also eine Gruppe glaube ich
sowieso schon mal nicht dass der fünf
sechs Leute sich in einem Boot chartern
und dann irgendwie zwei Tonnen
Sprengstoff da unterbringen die
Geschichte klingt nicht sehr
glaubhaft für mich und es ist irgendwie
ein bisschen komisch dass so viele
Details geschildert werden also es gibt
unterschiedliche Darstellungen darum und
wir es gibt keine Beweise was man
wahrscheinlich sagen kann ist dass diese
Sprengung jetzt da dazu also dass das
jetzt die Phase begonnen hat in der auch
mit mit Informationen mit viel
Informationen Politik gemacht
und dann sind wir da in einem
informationskrieger ich glaube selbst
wenn es mal Beweise geben sollte wir
werden es trotzdem nicht definitiv
wissen weil es gibt ja niemanden in
dieser Konstellation unabhängiges der
das beurteilen würde und das dann
genauso Form ändern würde da stecken ja
auf allen Seiten Interessen dahinter
diese Informationen vorzuenthalten also
insofern vermute ich mal das ist jetzt
so ein bisschen als Laie gesagt ich
vermute wir werden es nie so genau meine
Prognose ist das wird eine
Verschwörungstheorie wie jfkate werden
wir 50 60 Jahren noch drüber sprechen
und man muss vielleicht
so wenigstens das und dann machen wir
hier ich danke für den kurzen
Wortbeitrag und gebe an dieser Stelle
für eine interessante Runde danken zu
Markus Lanz der heute unter anderem
Thomas de maiziert zu Gast hat und wir
sehen uns wenn Sie mögen nächsten
Donnerstag wieder gleiche Stelle gleiche
Welle kommen Sie gut durch die Nacht und
bis dahin vielen Dank noch mal vielen
Dank
[Musik]